hello reject nation Greg the Alba Nader
here
Stacey Howard first and last name sound
like two first names but Howard would
not make a good female first name we're
gonna watch the trailer for Steve
McQueen's newest movie widows not Steve
McQueen the legendary action star not
Steven McQueen that actor on the Vampire
Diaries Steve McQueen the guy who makes
such fun films such as 12 years of slave
this sex addiction shame movie you know
hunger I'm just really like really
feeling good and now we're doing widows
you know it's just the right step for
this guy article about this like three
years ago it was originally a British TV
series oh so this is so Scooby it said
the 80s or something so this is like
contemporary set in America somewhere
and they've they changed up a little bit
but it's still the same basic plot so
they're kind of pulling from that like
nostalgic cool shelf super quick July
seventh keep your calendars open arena
Cinna lounge is gonna be letting the
real rejects along with the help of
Stacy Howard who will be their host and
event fans will be able to come out
we're gonna be doing some special type
of interactive thing with the audience
yes we'll be screening some stuff not
full-length movies you'll see what we're
talking about we'll have an official
announcement coming soon but just keep
your calendars open Saturday July 7th at
arena cinta lounge in the meantime if
you live in LA just go check out the
theater it's on Sunset Boulevard we're
into Cinna lounge calm people it's gonna
be a lot of fun widows widows not black
widows not spiders just just women who
don't have husbands yeah
cannon or what has happened in the world
that normal now passes as excellence
[Music]
already amen
when did we lower our standards oh hey
whoa what you don't see you don't know
my husband's aren't coming back
[Music]
Ronald
lived a lot of money
and now people want it from hell Danika
Lauria the best thing we have going for
us is being who we are why because no
one thinks we have the balls to pull
this off oh [ __ ]
[Music]
but this whole thing goes wrong I want
my kids to know that I didn't just sit
there and take it the city put yourself
where Viola Davis damn
[Music]
looks amazing Wow so we have shelves
everything works meet you let's talk
about every aspect about that number one
the cast looks [ __ ] sick mate that's
the most appealing part of like there's
two main factors on most appeal to is
the cast there's a cool flip that I've
seen her
Viola Davis we all know she's an amazing
dramatic actress she's gonna do that
here but she seems like she gets a
chance to be a badass yeah like an
action star like yeah
when she's walking with that bag and she
has like that wife beater on it and like
she just looks so intimidating and scary
there's the flip side with Michelle
Rodriguez where she's known for action
like she looks oh she gets the chance to
be a real character she's gonna have
like a real backstory yeah be a mom and
everything that just seems like a great
chance for these actresses to really
shine and the second factor that I'm
most excited for is Steve McQueen
normally does movies that are very much
these character study films that are
great but they're they challenge your
emotions here he'll have that but this
is the most high-concept plot I've ever
seen him do even in movies like 12 years
of slave there's a lot of really great
visual shots and you get to see some of
that cool stuff here just in a little
bit more of a dramatic action splice a
little bit yeah cuz I don't want to call
it an action movie even though there's
like action elements this is a high
concept drama with elements of action in
it yeah I don't want to call it an
action film because you have a female
writer who's gonna write the the female
perspective
yeah of this very intense and dark
action thriller drama that's what makes
it so different and what makes it so
appealing to me as a woman
and then as separately as a movie goer
has a huge movie fan this might be one
of my most anticipated that looks great
and they're putting in event the Brenda
November slob would you know you're
getting that Oscar push there yeah
Daniel Kaluga he looks like he's playing
some type of bad guy I guess so cuz
every shot he's just like someone's face
like that everyday I just like staring
it's very rare that you get the
opportunity for a bunch of females to be
in an action film it's not like that's
the whole purpose or point of them to be
in a real story with real stakes and
then it's not just oh we're women and we
want to like show yeah let's capitalize
on the whole like female empowerment it
doesn't I feel like a bad trailer could
have made it feel that way yeah or it
could have been if they wanted to go
more like comedic or like right shin
route then it could have been a lot
different yeah it could have felt
pandering and yeah this doesn't have
that vibe I love how Jon Bernthal like
after baby driver and this he takes on
these roles we were like Jon Bernthal
see one of the husbands yes like romper
that Liam Neeson or more part of the
husband duo there everything about this
looks really good and it looks like a
different element for Steve McQueen
actually to do something this reminds me
of heat if anything like that all this
is a female heat female heat not not the
female movie something I've been waiting
for for a long time yeah me enemy -
alright guys well hey that looks great
you guys can subscribe to that dog here
oh you're a dog whisperer now Cesar
Millan okay don't we can't change
anything so okay you guys can find me on
Twitter and Instagram at Stacy Oh Howard
you can also find my theater social
media at arena Center lounge on YouTube
Twitter Instagram Facebook
everything and we have an event with the
real rejects July 7th very excited about
that and subscribe and all that bye